[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
على المشي ، يجب أن يرسل الدماغ أمرًا إلى
منطقة رمز المفتاح
المسؤول عن التحكم في الحركات
عندما تكون هذه إصابة في الحبل الشوكي ، حيث يتم
قطع هذا الاتصال.
كانت فكرتنا هي إعادة إنشاء هذا
الاتصال مع  جسر رقمي يشبه
الاتصال الإلكتروني بين
الدماغ ومنطقة الحبل الشوكي
التي لا تزال سليمة والتي يمكنها التحكم في
كاتم صوت الساق
[موسيقى] قبل
بضعة أشهر تمكنت من القيام بذلك
للمرة الأولى بعد 10 سنوات من الوقوف
والحصول على  بيرة مع أصدقائي ، لذلك
كان الأمر رائعًا جدًا ، هل أرغب في استخدامها في
حياتي اليومية ، لذلك أنا سعيد جدًا لأنني أستطيع
مشاركة قصتي
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك [
تصفيق]
نجري عمليتين جراحيتين مختلفتين هناك
عملية جراحية واحدة في  على مستوى الدماغ نقوم
بوضع قطبين صغيرين في حج القحف
من أجل تسجيل إشارة الدماغ
وجراحة أخرى على مستوى
النخاع الشوكي حيث نضع أقطابًا كهربائية
أعلى الحبل الشوكي في المكان
المسؤول عن حركة الساق
[موسيقى  ]
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]